Egipto es el país más grande del mundo árabe,
con más de 95 millones de habitantes.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
Indonesia o Pakistán son mucho más grandes
que Egipto y también tienen mayoría musulmana
¿Verdad?
Tenéis razón.
Pero tenemos que distinguir entre árabe y
musulmán.
El Islam es una religión.
El árabe es una cultura, una raza y, sobretodo,
un idioma.
Y dentro del mundo árabe, Egipto es el país
más grande y uno de los más influyentes.
Eso explica que la liga de fútbol árabe
tenga su sede en la plaza TAHRIR, en el corazón
del EL CAIRO.
O que noticias como esta sean tan preocupantes.
Sin embargo, pese a las últimas noticias,
Egipto está cambiando mucho más rápido
de lo que nos podríamos imaginar ¿Recordáis
las primaveras árabes?
En 2011, miles de personas se manifestaron
durante días hasta derrocar al dictador HOSNI MUBARAK
Un año después, los Hermanos Musulmanes
se hacían con el poder, dispuestos a convertir
el país de las pirámides en una república
islámica.
Pero ahora, en 2017, la política egipcia
ha dado un giro de 180 grados.
Tanto como para ver noticias como ésta:
El gobierno egipcio cierra 27.000 mezquitas
para luchar contra el terrorismo
Así que ahora os preguntaréis, ¿Cómo hemos
llegado hasta aquí?
¿Se está convirtiendo Egipto en un país
secular?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… Vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LOS HERMANOS MUSULMANES
Tres nombres definen la historia de Egipto
en los últimos 60 años: Nasser, Sadat y
Mubarak.
Los tres tienen un elemento en común: presidían
una dictadura guiada por el socialismo árabe
dominante de la época.
Bien es cierto que Sadat, que reconoció el
Estado de Israel, y luego Mubarak, que vivió
la caída definitiva del bloque soviético,
Sin embargo, no tuvieron ninguno de los dos ningún problema
en cambiar los rublos por dólares y convertirse
en firmes aliados de Estados Unidos.
Pero ya sabéis que ser amigo de Estados Unidos
suele convertirte en objetivo de los radicales islámicos.
Por eso Mubarak aplastó con firmeza cualquier
movimiento islamista, cualquier elemento,
bien por atentados, que hubo unos cuantos
en los años 90, o bien porque estos radicales
pudieran suponer una amenaza para su poder.
Con este panorama, poco espacio tenía la
oposición contra Mubarak.
¿Y quién estaba enfrente del dictador?
Efectivamente, los Hermanos Musulmanes.
A pesar de operar en la clandestinidad, proscritos
desde el año 1954, la cofradía de los Hermanos
Musulmanes es el movimiento político mejor
organizado de Egipto desde que logró la independencia,
con miles de militantes de base y millones
de simpatizantes.
Su objetivo es convertir Egipto en una república
islámica, adoptando la sharia como ley y
el Corán como su guía política.
Sin embargo, los hermanos musulmanes no son
el único grupo integrista que hay en Egipto.
En este mismo país nos encontramos también
a los SALAFISTAS, que persiguen los mismos
fines pero de una forma totalmente distinta.
Estos señores que aparecen en la pantalla
son hermanos musulmanes.
Si os fijáis, veréis que visten como un
occidental ¿Verdad?
Pantalones vaqueros, camiseta, sudadera, etc…
Sin embargo, ahora os pongo imágenes de militantes
salafistas ¿Veis la diferencia?
Los salafistas llevan el atuendo tradicional
islámico: con su barba y zebiba en la frente
de tanto postrarse fervorosamente hacia la
Meca.
Como su propio nombre indica, los salafistas
quieren vivir como vivían los llamados SALAF,
es decir, los primeros musulmanes.
Cuando hablan, no dejan lugar a dudas sobre
cuales son sus objetivos políticos y religiosos.
Los hermanos musulmanes, por su parte, son
mucho más pragmáticos.
De entrada, están mucho mejor organizados.
Infiltran a sus miembros en las instituciones
de gobierno.
Y no tienen problema en hablar con medios
occidentales para lanzar mensajes como este.
“No somos terroristas.
La filosofía de los hermanos musulmanes está
inspirada por un entendimiento del Islam que
enfatiza los valores de la justicia social,
la igualdad y el estado de derecho”—Gehad
El-Haddad, portavoz de los Hermanos Musulmanes.
En otras palabras, que tanto los salafistas
como los hermanos musulmanes tienen los mismos
objetivos pero distintas estrategias.
De hecho, los salafistas se presentan a las
elecciones por un partido político totalmente
distinto, el partido AL-NOUR.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, los radicales
no se llevan bien entre ellos.
En realidad, se odian mutuamente.
En cualquier caso, durante los años 80, la
dictadura militar de HOSNI MUBARAK reprimió
a estos dos grupos a partes iguales.
Desde el año 1981, Egipto ha vivido en un
Estado de Emergencia, donde se metía en la
cárcel a todos los disidentes políticos.
Hablamos de miles de salafistas y de hermanos
musulmanes que pasaron décadas en la cárcel.
Como os podéis imaginar, ni la Unión Europea
ni Estados Unidos hicieron nada para evitar
esta represión.
A fin de cuentas, nadie quería ver a los
radicales islamistas en el gobierno.
Por si esto fuera poco, tras la guerra del
Yom Kippur, Egipto se había convertido en
un buen aliado de Israel.
Y su economía estaba on fire.
Si algo tiene este país desde la antigüedad
son los ingredientes perfectos para ser un
paraíso del turismo.
Se puede decir que hacia el año 2000 no te
daban un carnet oficial de viajero si no te
habías hecho un crucero por el Nilo o no
tenías una foto con las Pirámides.
Así que, durante 30 años, Mubarak tuvo carta
blanca para gobernar Egipto.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque en el año
2001, las cosas cambiaron!
Mubarak señala la sucesión en Egipto llevando
a su hijo a Washington
Esta noticia desató las iras de muchos ciudadanos
y del propio ejército.
Una cosa es tener un dictador y otra muy distinta es tener una dinastía de gobierno hereditaria.
Así es como surgió la primavera árabe que
terminó derrocando a Mubarak.
Un año después se celebraron elecciones
parlamentarias y presidenciales.
Hablamos de un país que llevaba décadas
en una dictadura.
Un país donde los únicos grupos de oposición
organizados eran los Hermanos Musulmanes y
los salafistas del Partido AL-NOUR.
Así que ¿Quién ganó las elecciones?
Efectivamente, los Hermanos Musulmanes, liderados
por este señor que veis en la pantalla, que
se llama MOHAMED MORSI.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
son mucho más complejas!
A no ser que seas Arabia Saudita y el petróleo
te salga por las orejas, el fanatismo islámico
no es la mejor receta económica para un país.
Así que, en menos de un año, la economía
de Egipto se vino abajo.
Miles de personas se fueron al paro y la inflación
se disparó.
Mientras tanto, las únicas preocupaciones
de Morsi eran islamizar el Estado y acabar
con la división de poderes para blindar su poder
con nuevas funciones para el presidente.
A esto hay que sumarle el ejército.
Como hemos visto antes, las fuerzas armadas
egipcias no se llevan bien con los grupos
islamistas.
Y así es como aparece en escena este otro
señor que aparece en pantalla.
El Mariscal ABDEL FATTAH EL-SISI, el por entonces
jefe de las fuerzas armadas.
El-SISI se reunió con todos los partidos
que estaban en la oposición, incluídos los
salafistas.
Les dijo “mirad, estos señores están hundiendo
el país… ayudadme para organizar un golpe
de estado y volver a poner las cosas en orden”.
Y como decimos en VisualPolitik… dicho y
hecho!
TIERRA DE FARAONES
En el año 2014, el ejército egipcio echó
a Morsi del Gobierno.
Su primera medida fue volver a ilegalizar
a los hermanos musulmanes.
Por supuesto que hubo protestas, cientos de
muertos y miles de detenidos.
Pero en el mes de junio de ese mismo año se convocaron
nuevas “elecciones”.
Y digo “elecciones” entre comillas, porque
el único candidato era El-SISI, que ganó
con un 97% de los votos.
(En realidad, en había un segundo candidato
aceptado por el régimen: HABDEEM SABAHI,
un periodista egipcio con nulas posibilidades.
De hecho, sólo sacó un 3% de votos)
¿Recordáis esa frase que decían en “El
caballero oscuro”: “O mueres como un héroe
o vives lo suficiente para verte convertido
en el villano”.
Pues esa parece ser la máxima de El-SISI.
De hecho, en los últimos años, Egipto ha
sido el país que más condenas de muerte
ha decretado en todo el planeta. Pero ¡No sólo
eso!
En sólo 3 años, el gobierno ha cerrado más
de 27,000 mezquitas.
Y la libertad de prensa es prácticamente
inexistente.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Que los integristas islámicos estarán en
pie de guerra ¿Verdad?
Pues lo cierto es que no ¿Recordáis que
os decíamos que los hermanos musulmanes y
los salafistas que se llevan a matar?
Pues no era ninguna broma.
Los islamistas ultraconservadores de Egipto
respaldan a Sisi, buscando eclipsar a la Hermandad
¡Pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
tampoco pintan bien para los salafistas!
Por supuesto, que EL-SISI les ha dado carta
blanca para que puedan ocupar los huecos que
han dejado los Hermanos Musulmanes.
En otras palabras, que todos los egipcios
creyentes que quieran ir a las mezquitas,
tienen que acudir a las que controla el imanato
del EL-AZHAR, que a su vez, está controlado
por el Estado.
¿Pero sabéis cuál es el problema?
¡Que cada vez hay menos creyentes en Egipto!
¡Tal cual como lo oís!
Para que os hagáis una idea, el porcentaje
de jóvenes que hacen sus oraciones diarias
ha caído a menos de la mitad en menos de
5 años.
Según el barómetro árabe, en el año 2011,
el 84% de la población apoyaba la SHARIA.
En 2016, ese porcentaje ha caído al 34%.
Y ¡No solo eso!
El propio EL-SISI celebra la navidad cristiana
en la catedral Copta del Cairo año tras año.
En otras palabras, que la sociedad egipcia
se está secularizando a marchas forzadas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta evolución
podría dar marcha atrás en cualquier momento!
De entrada, la popularidad de EL-SISI ha caído
en este año 2017.
A buena parte de los egipcios no les ha sentado
nada bien que haya cedido ante Arabia Saudí
la soberanía sobre dos islas en el Mar Rojo.
Tampoco les agrada que la represión no decaiga.
Es más, noticias como ésta recuerdan a los
tiempos de Mubarak.
Egipto declara el Estado de Emergencia después
de los ataques mortales a las iglesias
Por otro lado, la principal preocupación
de los egipcios, con diferencia, es la economía.
Aunque el desempleo está bajando, todavía
está por encima del 12% según las cifras
oficiales, ya que extraoficialmente se cree
que la tasa supera el 20%.
Sin embargo, el Gobierno parece embarcado
en proyectos faraónicos:
Egipto construirá una nueva capital financiada
por China
Si a esto le sumamos los ataques terroristas
y el hecho de que los Hermanos Musulmanes
saben moverse en la clandestinidad, tenemos
que el gobierno de EL-SISI está fracasando
en muchos aspectos.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que Egipto
puede convertirse efectivamente en un país
secular, al igual que su vecina Túnez?
¿O El-Sisi no es más que un regreso a la
etapa anterior a la Primavera Árabe?
Podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Si queréis conocer lo que ha ocurrido en
Túnez, haced click en este vídeo.
Y no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!